>>Lee Ann Potter: Good morning,
welcome to the purple stage.
I'm Lee Ann Potter, I
direct educational outreach
at the Library of Congress and
it is my pleasure to welcome you
to the 2018 National
Book Festival
and to the purple stage.
It is also my pleasure
to welcome
and introduce our next speaker.
David Shannon is good friend
to the Library of Congress
and the National Book Festival.
He has presented at the National
Book Festival three other times.
He is an author and
an illustrator of more
than 30 books for young readers.
Prior to creating children's'
books he worked in --
he worked in editorial
illustration in New York City
where his illustrations
have appeared in magazines
and newspapers that include:
Time, Newsweek, Rolling Stone,
and the New York Times as
well as on books and posters.
He began illustrating
children's books in 1988
with How Many Spots
Does a Leopard Have?
and Other Tales by
Julius Lester.
His writing credits include How
Georgie Radbourn Saved Baseball
which was named a New York
Times best illustrated book
in 1984, excuse me 1994.
And this semi- autobiographical
story No,
David which received
a Caldecott Honor.
He lives in Los Angeles with
his family and today David is
with us to officially
launch his newest book,
Grow Up David published
by Blue Sky Publishing.
After David's reading if
time allows he will take your
questions and he'll be signing
books from noon to one o'clock
in signing line number nine.
Welcome David Shannon.
[ Applause ]
>> David Shannon: Hi you guys
look really comfy don't go
to sleep OK.
It hurts my self esteem.
Alright so let's
see did it work?
Ah, yeah there we go.
It's David's birthday
yeah can you believe this?
No, David turned 20
years old this year.
Yeah it's been 20 years.
He still doesn't look a
day over five does he?
So yeah so I thought
I would just kind
of celebrate David's birthday
by just thanking everybody
out there who -- who's
made David last this long
and has had so much fun.
I'm just going to kind of share
with you guys some of the ways
that people have had fun with
No, David because that's --
that's been so rewarding for me.
So there he is.
I don't know if you know the
story about how I got the idea
for No, David, do you know that?
Well, I got the idea from a book
I made when I was a little kid.
It was eight pages long,
I drew a bunch of pictures
of me doing stuff I
wasn't supposed to do
and the only words in the
whole book were no and David.
Because that's all
I knew how to spell.
And my mom saved it.
And many years later she pulled
it out of her magic closet
and showed it to me and I
said this might make a good
children's' book.
So I wrote a few more words,
not a lot more, just a few.
And I drew new pictures
and that's where the No,
David that you know kind of --
this No, David that's
where he come from.
But this is what the
original looked like.
[laughter] There it is, yeah.
So when I first started
drawing the new version
of David I drew it
kind of realistically
and it lost all its personality
and just fell flat
and sat there.
And I went well what was
it about this original
that I was responding to?
So I went back and I looked
it and I tried to draw
like a five year old and that's
where the drawing
style came from.
Here's another piece.
And so whenever I got stuck
on anything I just went back
to the original so
the type style,
the writing and the
pointy teeth.
I don't know if you can
tell that's David on a chair
and that's a box
of Coco Krispies
with -- remember Snagglepus?
Exit stage left, that
-- that's what it is.
There's another one of me
getting into cookie dough
and do you guys realize this,
when I was a little kid cookie
dough ice cream hadn't been
invented yet.
Yeah I know terrible,
they were hard times --
they were hard times.
And so and you couldn't get it
in rolls like that at the store.
The only way you could get
cookie dough was to steal it
when your mom was making
chocolate chip cookies
because she would let
you lick the beaters.
You could do -- she'd
go here's the beater.
And then after that
you had to have more.
So then when her back was turned
you'd -- it was delicious.
So anyway, you could see
there's a lot of similarities
between like the that
no, David this no, David.
So even the pointy teeth and
stuff came from the original.
So let's see where am I?
So over the years all kinds
of people have been having fun
with David especially
like in schools.
So like teachers decorate
their doors with David,
and they decorate
their walls with David.
I love these.
And they decorate their
kids with David [laughter].
Sometimes I go into these
schools and there's whole walls
of Davids, like there's
about 100 of them and its --
it's pretty terrifying really.
It's like an army of Davids.
You know you think -- you
think zombies are frightening.
Sometimes they decorate
their principal.
Isn't that great?
I mean you know really.
Here's another one.
Personally I think
he's just made
for a Christmas ornament,
don't you?
They make cakes, there's
a lot of baking involved
with celebrating
David's birthday.
And cake pops.
And this kid's name
is David by the way.
Yeah, is that beautiful?
Oh, well now it's also -- it's
also very gratifying to be able
to influence the
youth of America.
My favorite part of this picture
is the hand coming in get, get,
get your finger out
of your nose.
Now just in case though people
you know don't accuse me
of your kid reading my --
my books and engaging
in bad behavior
because it's not
just the David book.
It's not just David that does
that, you see that happens
to be the picture he's
looking at right there.
No influence there at all
because actually all my
books make kids do this.
Yeah that's a bad --
that's Alice the fairy.
But by far the most -- the
most wonderful thing is all the
letters and the -- I have
a whole collection of No,
David books that kids have made.
And sometimes it's you know
maybe I should've called it no,
your kids name here.
But they're just
wonderful, they're all --
there's yes, David books
and no, David books
and David goes to the zoo.
Fantastic stuff and I
thought I'd read a couple
of the letters.
Here's a few of the
drawings first of all.
I wish I could draw
like this, seriously.
There's David's rock band,
heavy metal I'm sure.
Look at that one.
So here's a few of these
letters, they're just -
they're really hilarious.
Ok this is -- this is
the good kind right here.
Dear crazy Mr. Davey thank you
for coming I absolutely
love your books
and I hope you make more.
I hope I get to see you
more, I love all your books
and I am obsessed with them.
You are -- you are the
best book writer ever.
If I get to meet you again
I will scream with joy.
So this letter I -- I saved
and whenever my family gives me
too much guff I pull out this
and say, let me just read
this letter to you again.
But then I get these too.
Dear David Shannon, I've
read No, David recently
and I liked it but maybe
you should right more words.
You also should add a little
bit more detail to the picture.
Like when David was reaching
for the cookies you should
add little drops of sweat
since he was determined
and frustrated.
You also should write the words
of what the sounds are from like
when David was banging
pots and pans.
You should add like
a crash or bang.
I'd like that.
Then the book would
be more exciting
and fiction readers
would read it.
They would get so,
so, so into the book.
They wouldn't know
where they were,
that David Shannon is how I
want you to change this book.
A lot of critics out there.
I just read your book No, David
could you please just make it
so David has a towel
instead of the nakedness.
Do you guys know that
picture of David running
down the street naked?
Yeah. He says could you imagine
what kid's parents would say?
The parents would
say, never check out
or read this book again.
That's why I think you should
take the nakedness out.
Dear David Shannon, don't
eat gum, you are nasty.
Listen to the teacher.
You are bad, I don't' like you.
David you are very bad, I
don't very, very like you.
I don't like you so
much love Nate ps.
I like your books.
Yeah, so -- so I wasn't going
to do anymore David books.
I had put that behind me because
each -- each book I tried to --
I don't want to do the same
book over and over again.
I tried to sort of explore a
different level of authority
or a different set of rules
because David's all about kind
of breaking the rules right.
And so like after No, David
the next book was David Goes
to School because
that's the next level
of authority is your
teacher right.
She's the next person that
says no to you after your mom.
So but my editor was
celebrating her 25th anniversary
of her imprint and
David was celebrated --
is celebrating his 20th birthday
so my editor kept
saying I'd sure
like to have a new David book.
I say no. I'd sure
like to have one.
And then I realized I'd
been kicking around an idea
about my big brother --
about the relationships
between siblings.
And I say well what am I doing?
This is perfect for a No, David
book because your relationship
with your older sibling is
you know that's a whole --
that's a whole new set of rules.
It's a whole new set of --
of things that you
get in trouble about.
You know brothers
get in trouble.
So that's where this book
came from and let's see.
So the interesting thing
about siblings is they live
under the same roof,
in the same house,
but they have two different
sets of rules don't they?
So like the older
brother gets to do things
that the younger brother can't
because he's bigger
and he's older.
But the little brother
can get away with things
that the older brother can't.
So and eventually that
creates some tension
which is always good for a
story -- a little conflict.
So David wants to play
football but he's too little.
Stop following me, anybody
here have a little brother
or a little sister?
Do they follow you around?
They do don't they, yeah.
Yeah, stop following me.
But of course David
bothers his brother too,
because his brother has
things like homework.
You know his job
is to do homework;
David's job at this point
is just to be silly.
So that doesn't go together.
And my brother -- my
brother was very concerned
about being mature.
He would always say to
me you are so immature.
So we -- we -- my little sister
and I called him Mr. maturity.
And he's -- he's still
kind of like that.
Yeah, but David finds ways at
getting back at his brother.
Oh, but then his
brother retaliates.
This is how it happens, can
you guys see the loogy coming
down on the left there?
Yeah, this is a true story
ah-huh and so if I yell for --
it says, go ahead call mom.
So if I yelled for help guess
where that loogy
went, in my mouth.
Yeah, otherwise he
would just drop it down
and suck it back down.
And then drop it down,
and suck it back up.
Yeah horrible things.
But I've polled kids on
this and this is still going
on today, this activity.
So eventually they
both get in trouble
because they were roughhousing.
But in the end -- so
after, after they get
in trouble mom says go
outside, go outside and play.
And David finally
gets to play football.
And this is how it
happens is that his brother
and their friends they're
starting a football game
and they only -- they have
an uneven number of players.
They have seven guys
or nine guys
and so they finally go
David, you want to play?
And David says yes and of
course he gets flattened.
But in the end both David
and his brother do grow
up just a little bit.
And that's how Grow
Up David ends.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So we have -- we have time for
questions I hope, we do, good.
Alright anybody got a question?
What's your question?
Ok good question.
He asked how long it took
me to make Grow Up David.
Well I'll tell you it takes
a long time to make a book
because I always start out --
whenever I'm doing a book I read
the story a whole bunch of times
so I know it really well.
And then I get out
a big piece of paper
and I start making little
tiny sketches called thumbnail
sketches in pencil.
And they're really scribbly
and I make hundreds of them
because I'm just
trying to figure
out what picture is going
to go on which page?
And it's kind of like a puzzle
because if I change something
on page 20 sometimes I
have to go back to page 12
and change something there too.
So when I get that
all figured out,
then I do full size pencil
drawings and make lots
of mistakes and I erase a
lot and sometimes I get mad
and I crumple it up and
throw it over my shoulder
and go that's terrible.
And then I run back and I
get it and smooth it out
and go really ah
it wasn't so bad.
And then when I get the
drawings all done I do full
color paintings.
And then I send those
to the book company called the
publisher and they take pictures
of the paintings and they
put the words next to them
and sew them all together
and put the hard cover on.
And so all of that
takes about a year --
takes me about a
year to do a book.
So yeah, a long time huh?
The David books take
a little bit less time
because I don't have
to stay in the lines
when I color them
which is always nice.
Yeah.
>> Who are your enemies?
>> Who are my enemies
[laughter]?
I hope not you.
My enemies, I've never,
ever been asked that before.
You know I -- I -- I
try not to have enemies,
I suppose Voldemort would be
-- would be one of my enemies.
Well sometimes my brother was
definitely my enemy, yeah,
and then other times he
was my very best friend.
So it's always nice to turn
enemies into best friends.
Yeah.
>> What is it like
to be an author?
It's absolute hell.
Because you have to
come up with ideas
and you know actually
I am always
so grateful whenever
an idea strikes me.
You know because you always
are worried they'll stop.
So what I do is I keep a --
I keep a special notebook
and I write down all my
ideas so I don't forget them.
I even write down the
ideas I think are dumb
because sometimes they turn
out to be the best ones.
Or they'll make me think
of a really good idea.
So you know -- and then
sometimes I'll have an idea
and I'll say oh, this is
an incredibly great idea.
I am a genius and I'll write
down and then I'll look
at it the next day
and I'll say oh, oh,
oh this is a terrible
idea I am not a genius.
So you never know, so I
always keep a notebook.
>> How come you never see
the older brother's face?
>> Oh, that's a good question.
Well that started out with No,
David where you don't see the
any of the grown-ups face.
You don't see the mom's face.
And there were two
reasons for that.
One is so that it stays at
David's like a kid's eye level,
a kid's eye view of everything.
The other thing was I
wanted kids to be able
to picture their own mom.
Right, I didn't want to have you
know a different mom I wanted
them to sort of like whenever
they read all those things
that their mom says to them.
I wanted them to be able
to picture their mom.
So in this case I
want kids to be able
to picture their big
brother or big sister.
>> What is your favorite
David book?
>> What is my favorite
Well I think it's probably
got to be No, David.
Because that's the one
that really reminds
me of being a kid.
So and I try to do as
many things to remind me
of being a kid as I can.
What's your favorite one?
Do you have a favorite one?
Oop we don't have
a mic I can't hear.
>> Grow Up David.
>> Oh it is ok.
Well that's great.
Well I -- a lot of times I like
the one that I've just finished.
So that's a good idea.
>> I have two questions
the first on is,
is there going to
be No, David Here?
>> Is there going to
be No, David here.
You mean is he coming?
Good gravy I hope not.
>> And the other
question is, never mind.
>> Oh, I know what your
second question was.
It's what was I going to ask?
[laughter].
Ok we got a couple more.
What?
>> How old is David?
How old are you?
>> Three.
>> Well David's probably just
a little bit older than you.
I always think that
he's about five.
But you never know I
mean he's kind of as old
as whatever kid is
reading about him.
Well let's just say
he's ageless.
Five ok five.
>> Do you have, do you
still have a westie?
>> Oh, good question, yeah do
you guys know about Fergus?
Yeah, Fergus is my little
white dog and I put him
in all my books somewhere.
Sometimes he's really hidden,
and sometimes he's easy to find.
Sometimes he's really hard to
find, but he's in all my books.
And he really was my dog
but I have some sad news,
Fergus passed away but
he was 19 years old.
Yeah I know.
I'll do the math for you
that's 133 in dog years.
So he had a very good life
and now I have a new
westie and his name is Roy.
And he's completely
different from Fergus.
The best example
is Fergus thought
that he was a human;
Roy thinks I'm a dog.
Yeah and I'm doing a new
book about Roy right now,
it's called Roy Digs Dirt.
And he does, but he -- I
drew him a little differently
so he doesn't -- I didn't
want him to look like Fergus
so he doesn't really look
like a westie in the new book.
But he has the personality and
I'm going to keep putting Fergus
in all my books so keep
looking for him OK.
But listen don't tell Roy
because Roy thinks it's him OK.
Alright you guys it's
time to vacate the stage
for the next incredible author.
Thank you so much for coming.
Thanks to everybody
who's had fun with No,
David and the National
Book Festival.
Thank you.